Guy Verhofstadt, welcome to Conflict Zone.
Let's talk first about the migrants who drowned
last week since that's the crisis of the moment.
Do you think this is going to be the catalyst
for some new European policies on migration?
I hope so, because this tragedy in the North
Sea is not the first tragedy, and we have
seen so many casualties, tragedies in the
Mediterranean.
Now this is happening on the North Sea, so
I hope it is a catalyst finally to have a
common European migration policy.
Because it's already more than 20 years that
we are talking about a common migration policy.
And it never happened because a common migration
policy could avoid the tragedies, as we have
seen last week.
France called for urgent talks to discuss
this tragedy, but then it disinvited a British
minister because he didn't like one of Boris
Johnson's tweets.
You don't do that if you're serious about
finding solutions, do you?
I don't think that you start to do such talks
with tweets.
That's maybe the way Trump did his policies,
but that's not the way we do it inside the
European, inside the European Union.
So I think more important is to concentrate
ourselves on what could avoid such tragedies.
And again, there, a change in the European
migration and asylum policy is absolutely
key.
Like, there is also a need for the UK, for
the United Kingdom to understand that they
are now out of the European Union and they
need to take their own responsibility for
that migration and asylum policy.
What did you do...
I think?
I think they understand that.
I'm talking about diplomatic grounds.
I hope so.
I'm not.
I'm not so sure that — maybe you understand
that — I'm not so sure that the British
government, that Boris Johnson understands
that.
This diplomatic standoff may be great fun
for governments, but the only people who are
going to get hurt by this are the migrants.
Isn't it time for everyone to stop playing
games with these people's lives?
It's the time now to do what most governments,
especially also the British government, but
also other governments, have always avoided
to do.
That is to develop a common migration and
asylum policy that is based not on unanimity,
a ruling on the decision by unanimity, but
on qualified majority.
Because that's the reason that we don't have,
[for] the last 20 years, a common migration
and asylum policy.
It is already since 1999 that we decided that
migration would be a common policy in the
Union, and since then nothing has happened.
And the first thing to do is to create and
to establish a common legal migration policy.
Because many of these tragedies are the consequence
of the fact that we don't have a legal migration
policy in the Union.
And the second thing to do is to have common
asylum standards in the Union.
So there is no shopping anymore possible.
And the third thing to do is to really better
manage our outside borders of the Union.
I want to, I want to come on to the outside
borders...
Unfortunately...
I want to come on to the outside borders in
a minute.
But if EU member countries can't agree on
a life-and-death issue like this, what's the
point of the EU?
The point of the EU is that only on the EU
level, you can manage this.
You're seeing it with Britain.
Britain cannot manage this, although it needs
to ask the European Union to take action.
Otherwise tragedies will continue.
Tragedies for people who want to reach and
want to go to the United Kingdom.
And the point is, our point is, as Europe,
as a European Parliament, we have already
said for years and I hope that in the next
conference on the future of Europe, we will
achieve that, that we need to get rid of unanimity.
The problem is that the fact that you need
the approval of 27 member states before you
can act.
And in the meanwhile, such tragedies are happening
because of this impossibility to go forward
on migration policy because [of] the unanimity
requirement that exists today.
OK, but at the same time that while this is
going on, the EU...
It's not the only field.
Is not the only field.
The EU is facing a major credibility issue
because it doesn't just sell goods around
the world, it tries to sell values as well.
And I'm wondering which values the EU was
selling when Poland was filmed tear gassing
helpless migrants on the border with Belarus
and showering them with water cannon in freezing
temperatures?
Not the greatest advert for EU values, was
it?
Doesn't it doesn't make you wonder want to
weep?
No, now, you are not very objective in the
way you put your question, because the problems
at the Polish border are not a problem caused
by the European Union or caused by Poland.
They are problems caused by Lukashenko, by
Belarus.
You think this was an appropriate way to treat
the migrants?
To tear-gas them?
...to use and abuse migrants.
Well, and they got abused by Poland, didn't
they.
Again, that's a problem that has been.
Now, it's a problem caused by Lukashenko,
so it's not very objective, though, to inverse
the roles and to do as the migrants on the
border between Belarus and Poland are a problem
that has been caused by the European Union,
that's not.
And you know it very well.
And what we have done in the meanwhile, is
to try to have agreements with those countries
where these people come from.
So to avoid that they are abused by a dictatorship
in the neighborhood of the European Union,
as has been the case the last week and months.
And so they were abused by other people, then,
weren't they.
I deplore, as [do] you, the use of violence
and deaths.
So some of the deals that you've entered into
have resulted, and I'm talking about the particularly
dirty deal with the Libyan Coast Guard, paid
in effect now by the EU to hunt down migrant
boats in the Mediterranean and take the people
back home to deal with human rights violations
are visited on them.
One thing I guess I have to tell you one thing,
it may be your next time you don't invite
me to have your interview.
You invite the commissioner who is responsible
for that because exactly as a member of Parliament,
I have criticized this towards the European
Commission.
I am not the member of Parliament who has
to defend the policies of the European Union.
So next time you take the European Commissioner
responsible for these matters and you ask
him these questions, I'm as critical as you
on the fact that is happening.
And that's the reason why I think that European
migration and asylum policy needs to become
a European Union matter, while it is not today,
because all elements that you have put forward,
the problems in the North Sea and the tragedy
we have seen in the North Sea, the problems
at the border between Poland and Belarus.
The problems in the Mediterranean towards
Libya.
And people coming from there, and abuse there,
are all the consequence of the fact that our
member states are responsible for that and
the European Union is not.
So it's not a question of the European Union.
It's a question of a lack of European Union,
a lack of European migration and asylum policy.
But next time, my proposal to you is: invite
the commissioner responsible for it because
I am as critical towards what is happening
in the Mediterranean and in the North Sea,
as you do.
You're critical about it, the media is critical
about it.
The reports have been coming in and going
to the UN and human rights organizations for
a long time, and yet nothing gets done about
it.
Why do you think that is?
Because like I will explain for the third
time or the fourth time now, that this policies
for the moment are still policies of the member
states, because there is no unanimity inside
European Council to change this migration
policies, even at the moment when so many
people, refugees came from Syria, and the
conflict in Syria towards Europe...
Yeah...
Mrs Merkel said, "ok, wir schaffen das, we're
going to pick them, we're going to take them
inside Germany."
That was a national measure without consultation
with the others.
So we need absolutely a radical change in
the way European migration and asylum policy
is treated in the Union.
And we have to do it in a common way.
We have to do it on the European level with
a good border management with common asylum
and migration conditions and with a legal
migration path.
Because a lot of the tragedies in the Mediterranean
and in the North Sea are the consequence of
the absence today of a legal way to come,
to work, to be active as a migrant in Europe.
You claimed earlier this year that EU integration
has been enormously important, you said, to
enshrine rules, rights and freedoms into our
societies in Europe.
But in a number of EU countries, those rules
exist only on paper, don't they?
And you're powerless, as you said, to do anything
about that.
Hungary and Poland, for instance, with all
the rule of law issues, they know how to game
the system, don't they?
And they can paralyse it if they want to hold
up discussions on the budget, hold up this
and that.
So far from enshrining your rules, the EU
is being strangled by them, isn't it?
No, absolutely not.
There is a way to tackle this.
But there is an unwillingness in the European
Council under the heads of states and government
and under the prime ministers to tackle that
problem.
What I expect is that with a new German government
arriving, a government of socialists, liberals
and Greens, that this new government will
be far more critical on this issue, let's
be honest about it.
Until now, we didn't tackle the problem in
Hungary.
We didn't tackle it in Poland because the
European Council, under the leadership of
Mrs. Merkel, was not capable to do it.
The parliament asked for it...
You said they were gutless.
They failed to have courage.
Sorry.
The commission launched the procedure on it,
and the European Court of Justice also took
its responsibility.
The only institution which didn't take its
responsibility was the European Council, and
I think my expectation is that with the new
German government arriving in power now, this
will change and we will see really a European
Union who is active using the instruments
to make sure that the values in the European
Union are also applied in countries like Poland
and Hungary.
You've criticized European leaders for lack
of courage.
You said the, the instruments, for instance,
with, for dealing with rule of law issues
in Poland and Hungary, existed.
"The instruments exist," you said, "only the
courage among leaders is failing."
So why do you think EU leaders are so gutless
on this issue?
For the simple reason that in the council,
everything is decided between them.
I have never seen in the European Council,
and I was a long time a member of the European
Council, one colleague attacking another colleague.
One colleague criticizing another colleague.
One colleague sanctioning, I should say, another
colleague around the table.
That doesn't help.
That doesn't work in European Council.
Therefore, I think with the arrival of a new
German government, I think that we will see
European Council far more critical towards
what is happening in Poland and in Hungary.
And on top of that, I think that in the future,
we need to maybe to change the instruments
and change the instruments, that means to
give to the European Court of Justice the
capability, the competence not only to give
in judgments about what is happening in Poland
and Hungary, but also to decide on sanctions.
What is the case in every normal rule of law
system in every country?
So I think that fundamentally and ultimately,
it will be necessary to give a new competence
to the European Court of Justice what to give
them the possibility to decide on sanctions
towards countries that they are not applying
the fundamental values of the Union.
You mentioned earlier the Conference on the
Future of Europe, which you're co-chairing,
yet another inquiry into what Europeans want
from their institutions.
Has there ever been an organization that did
so much navel-gazing and introspection?
No, it's not, it's not consulting what is,
it's absolutely not that.
What we are organizing with a conference on
the future of Europe is an unseen exercise
while we try to combine representative democracy
with participatory democracy.
The citizens where you're talking about, in
total 800 selected, randomly selected people,
are not, are not there to give their opinion,
and it's over, no.
They are participating in the decision-making
process.
It's for the first time, I think, in a modern
democracy that citizens are directly involved
in the decision-making process.
That is what we are doing.
But, Guy Verhofstadt — not many them, and
not many of them are there, not many of them.
The numbers taking part on this national digital
platform are so small as to be almost irrelevant.
I don't, know.
I don't know.
There are for the moment, there are, for the
moment, four million people who are on the
platform who have got access to the digital
platform, the Conference on the Future of
Europe.
There are 10 and 10 of several tens of thousands,
who were on daily basis debating on the future
of the European Union and in top of that,
that have been in a scientific way, 800 people
selected — and all these people have nothing
to do with European Union — to participate
in the decision-making process.
We have seen such what we call Citizens Convention
already in France, already in Ireland, already
in Germany.
But it's for the first time that it is organized
on a pan-European level.
And my expectation of this exercise is not
to listen to the citizens because we know
what the citizens want.
We have the Eurobarometer, we have surveys
like it's in the case, also in Britain.
No: the big difference is that the citizens
are selected will continue to participate
in not only formulating recommendations, but
also in the answers the, yeah, the politicians
will give to their wishes and to the recommendations.
You said: "to regain people's trust in democracy,
we need to fundamentally revisit the way our
democracies work so they are for and with
the people."
Instead of that, why not concentrate on results?
Yes, find a way for 27 disparate countries
to pull together on the major problems that
are facing them, something that they have
conspicuously failed to do so far.
Well, for the simple reason that the pressure
that can be created by the participation of
the citizens will be so huge that I am, I
am confident that we can find two ways to
break the resistance off of some member states
to go forward inside the European Union.
We need the power of the people.
We need the power of the citizens inside this
conference to go through barriers, for example,
the barrier of unanimity.
And secondly, we need this also this new type
of democracy because our liberal democracy,
your liberal democracy, our liberal democracy
is under threat today.
Under threat from outside the European Union,
China, Russia — but also under threat inside,
because of the social media, social media
like Facebook are undermining our liberal
democracy.
So a direct involvement of the citizens inside
the decision-making process of the European
Union is really the good answer.
I think a real answer towards this degrading
new liberal democracy through the social media
as we see it today.
Why?
Why is Facebook undermining your liberal democracy?
Is that is that the....
I think that's that's obvious, at least everybody
understands that when you go on Facebook and
you put I don't know what, for example, Chinese
Communist Party on your Facebook, that for
the next five or 10 years, you will receive
mostly only posts and see posts and messages
concerning the Chinese Communist Party.
If that's the only thing you put in, yes.
But if you put in a whole raft of other things,
you'll get some references to explain.
Sorry, let me explain.
The algorithms behind the system of Facebook
are made in such a way that at the end, people
only see what they think and not the counter
argument.
And that's a very good model to make profits
in the, in US maybe, in United States, but
it's a very bad model for the pluralism in
our liberal democracies.
Let's come back to the EU.
The question that is often raised about accountability
among the commission.
Do you believe that this commission is accountable?
How many of its commissioners ever get sacked?
Once in its history?
One since 1958?
Is there accountability in the commission?
No, that's not.
That's not true.
That's not true what you are saying.
You forgot to mention the fact that this parliament
at a certain moment has dismissed and put
home a whole commission once, and also a commission
president in the past.
Once.
Well, that's not true.
So there have been many examples of, of that,
but it's true that we need to increase the
power of this European Parliament to make
it a real European democracy.
And the power, additional power that is European
Parliament needs is power on taxation.
That is something we are missing for the moment.
And the second thing what we need is the right
of initiative for this European Parliament
to initiate new proposals.
So if you tell me that there is not enough
power for European Parliament in controlling
the commission and in controlling the council
and in developing a number of policies, you're
right.
Yes.
We talked earlier about what you called "failing
courage among Europe's leaders."
In 2018 you went further and you said "the
union tends to be rather weak in the face
of global challenges."
That was pretty much the case, wasn't it,
when Donald Trump was president, allowing
Europe to be lectured like naughty school
children about NATO funding and who you could
trade with and who you couldn't?
Pretty degrading, wasn't it?
Yeah.
But yeah, but it didn't fundamentally change
with Biden, Biden or Trump.
Both are criticizing a European Union for
that and for good reasons, not because there
is not sufficient funding, but because there
is not sufficient cooperation inside Europe.
You know that Europe is spending, is spending
more than China on on military expenditures.
We are spending in Europe — without even
the UK — four times more than the Russians
are military.
The problem of our military in Europe is not
the level of spending.
The problem is that we do it 28 times, 27
times now after the Brexit, and that we duplicate
everything 27 times.
We spend more or less 35% of the Americans
on military, and we can only do 10% of the
operations of the American army.
What does it mean if you spend 25% of the
Americans get only 10% of the operations?
That you're three to four times less effective.
And that's the consequence of duplication.
So my plea is that the fastest it's possible
we'll create this European defense community
as a pillar of NATO.
The European pillar of NATO.
And that's the real answer to our geopolitical
weakness and not spend a little bit more of
tax money as we do to it today.
But do you agree that one of the commissioners,
Thierry Breton, said the other day, that "something
is broken in trans-Atlantic relations," and
that's neither a reference to Trump nor Biden.
Is there something that he was talking about
temporary or is the trans-Atlantic alliance
coming unstuck irrespective of who's in the
White House?
Now, what, what I see is the absolute need
for reform of the North Atlantic [Treaty]
Alliance and why I'm saying that when Joe
Biden is coming a few weeks ago to Europe,
to the NATO summit, he's talking about China.
He's talking about China.
That is in the South Pacific, no?
That's not the North Atlantic.
That means that our defense issues today are
not related only to the environment in the
North Atlantic, but are worldwide, and that
there is a need to reform the NATO into a
global world alliance of democracies and that
on a continental scale, that means that the
North American continent, the Asian continent,
European continent, has to do a real effort
to create defense communities to defend our
liberal democracies.
So the NATO is today still an alliance of
individual countries.
And what I think is that we need to transform
it into a real alliance of continental defense
communities defending liberal democracy.
You want to reform NATO.
You want to reform rules inside the European
Union.
You want to change the unanimity rule, you
want a lot of reforms and you want a federal,
a federal Europe at the end of it, a sort
of one-size-fits-all.
It's ... what if you don't get any of these
reforms?
That's absolutely not true, that...
You have a complete misunderstanding of what
federalism is, because a one fit for all,
that's not federalism, that's the opposite.
It's the opposite.
You see it in the United States of America.
United States of America, all 50 states with
50 different constitutions, with 50 different
armies and so on and so on.
So when I am, I'm a federalist.
That's true.
But federalist, for me, means that everything
what you can do on the local level, you do
on the local level; what you can better do
on a national level, what you do better on
the national level.
But where there is an added value on the European
level, that you have to do on the European
level, and it's the only way for the Europeans
to defend our interests, our values on in
the new world order that is emerging today
— is emerging — it exists already today.
There will be a time where it will be the
Chinese who will decide on our standards or
will be deciding on our way of life.
And the only way to counter that is to organize
a federal, democratic in diversity, European
continental European Union.
Guy Verhofstadt, it's been good to have you
on Conflict Zone, thank you very much.
OK, bye bye.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Bye.